hard truth on men women and money 50
common money mistakes and how to fix
them he joins us this morning kevin
thanks for joining us you're a brave man
the look in that woman's face i think
she was a stand-in for many who thought
huh you're defending this you know i
think we vilify the creation of wealth
we vilify capitalism it's become very
unpopular to talk about successful
people but you know i what i'm trying to
say is it's not fantastic to be poor and
i don't like disparity in wealth and or
poverty these are all bad things but
let's celebrate the facts all right if
you look back the last 30 years
42 percent of the world's population was
in desperate poverty today is 17 percent
thank you capitalism thank you that's
what made that happen all right if you
go back to 1900 70 of the world's
population was illiterate today it's 17
thank you capitalism thank you let's
celebrate what's working and the metrics
show us the numbers show us that our
system works so let's not vilify it
right people become consumed with envy
however when they think they can't
become
rich
the system works as long as people see a
plausible path to success but if they
think that that plot that path is
blocked then they get resentful and your
society comes becomes unstable no it's
not blocked that's not true the american
dream is alive and well you can see the
evidence of it look at the success of
shark tank people starting ideas and
businesses creating wealth groove book
last friday they became millionaires in
a week as a result of their product
getting on the show there's every
evidence everywhere that what we do and
what works in america capitalism creates
wealth and those people pay taxes yes 30
to 50 percent depending where they are
and that goes back into the system to
support all kinds of initiatives
including helping people that are in
poverty it's so funny you were from
canada yes originally
you must be the fifth canadian i've met
in the united states reminding america
that the market works is this a
remarkable turn there's no place in the
world like america when i started my
business
i wanted to come here to create it and
grow it i was in a jurisdiction ontario
in the mid 90s where they had a
socialist government i had to leave it
was an oppressed environment you
couldn't build a business there taxes
were crazy nobody wanted to give me
money i moved to boston when i wanted to
create wealth and hire 10 000 people
around the world i came to america this
is where you create business this is the
heartbeat of creation of wealth and
capitalism and anytime someone tries to
change that they're making a huge
mistake
calling business leaders fat cats and
saying that this is a bad thing is
un-american this is the place where
everybody around the world wants to come
to be successful what's wrong with that
you think that's changing oh yeah the
tonality today is unhealthy in my view
you know when i came to boston
bain capital was not a swear word they
gave me 200 million dollars to help me
build my business globally and hire
thousands of people and pay millions in
taxes
why in the world would we vilify that i
think something's really gone awry and i
think it'll come back
at some point but right now we should be
talking about creating jobs through
small business there's six million small
businesses today in america we ask
ourselves why there's unemployment over
seven percent because we made it so
difficult for them through regulations
last year
2800 new federal regulations
who can even comply with that we're
competing with the chinese now we're in
a football game we've got to make it
easier it's crazy
kevin o'leary author of cold hard truth
on men women and money 50 common
mistakes money mistakes and how to fix
them great book thank you really
interesting thank you you're a brave man
to say that i appreciate it take care